[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
proud
[Music]
and be free
[Music]
no more
[Music]
in my brain and go
home to my lord
and be free
[Music]
[Music]
my and be free
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
me
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
me
[Music]
so
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
me
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
so
[Music]
oh
no more
[Music]
[Applause]
is
[Music]
oh
[Applause]
[Music]
in my dreams and go home
to my lord and be
[Music]
free
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
no more
[Music]
and be free
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
is
[Applause]
[Music]
me
[Applause]
free
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Music]
of this house
clergy know the dignitaries and on
behalf of his white
family we say thank you for coming i
need you guys
and say i'm a vip and i'm a guest as a
right man
you may be
and so we're going to try to move this
program along relatively quickly
um so this family can get some rest
so this time we're going to have our
scriptures
man
demetrius right
family that has been visited by a loss
and sometimes a loss so suddenly it can
seem like
darkness is just descended
to the floor
to a community that's dealing with
disruption
joseph c price who was the founding
president of livingston
college said i hope you could bear this
in mind it matters not
how dark
one associated with the issues of grief
the third chapter 23rd
verse jeremiah says i remember
my affliction and my wife
the bitterness and the god my soul still
remembers and
sinks within me but there's good news
he says yet this i call to mine and
therefore
i have hope because of the lord's great
love
they did not consume his compassions
failed not their new
everyone great oh god
is our faithfulness hope in god
amen those that are willing and able if
we can stand for prayer
two things can be true at the same time
there's joy and there's pain
there's loss and there's gain i want to
acknowledge everything
that's in the building we may not
subscribe to the way that we subscribe
you may not believe in the way that we
believe
but one thing that we can rejoice in
before i start this prayer
regardless what your demographics
regardless when you believe is that we
experience this week the god of justice
today
that we will see the poorness of justice
and we will each of this food
not just in the name before our truth
and our truth and i pray through this
truth
that you are not short concerning the
promises
so even though right now we are trusting
god that we do not understand
even though right now we be honest we
don't even understand why we're here
why did this happen but the beauty
and the velocity of faith is trusting
the god that i cannot understand
so with that glean to our grandparents
faith
we glean to our ancestors faith and we
declare
and decree that this day and the days to
come
that he will be a comforter in the midst
of the storm
[Music]
[Applause]
is
my heart is ready to receive a blessing
from the lord
even in the midst of what's going on
anybody still want to receive a blessing
from the lord
[Music]
[Music]
and my heart is ready
to receive
a blessing from you just waiting ahead
if you came to receive it
hallelujah
[Music]
yes
[Music]
[Music]
me
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Applause]
please don't
[Applause]
[Music]
my heart is ready
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
please
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
we
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
i
[Music]
[Applause]
hallelujah
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
i love you jesus
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
lord
[Music]
[Music]
hallelujah
[Music]
much too soon
[Music]
[Music]
do
foreign
somebody man
let's give them a hand as they come
to witness what about to take place
[Music]
how many know that god is still good
in spite of our troubles and struggles
and
all the situations
[Applause]
how
hmm
hi
[Music]
uh
[Music]
ah hey
[Music]
[Music]
hmmm
[Music]
bye
[Music]
hey
[Music]
hey
[Music]
hey
[Music]
hey
[Music]
ah
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hey
[Music]
hey
[Music]
hello
[Music]
oh
[Music]
hello oh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hello
[Music]
um
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Applause]
you
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Music]
hallelujah
[Music]
[Music]
black folks that's none other than
the one and only benjamin trump
justice for dante wright
let me have you join me
in proclaiming that dante
bright life matters so his
mother katie and aubry wright
will know that we believe it when we
quote it up on your feet if you would
dante
[Applause]
like
[Music]
as we come to lay him to rest
but most importantly we celebrate his
life and we define his
legacy once more dante
[Applause]
[Music]
deliver the eulogy as only my mentor
came
but i want to acknowledge for you
in this plea for justice along with my
distinguished co-counsels
attorney antonio ramanucci
and attorney jeff songs and attorney
carol powell
lexing we want to acknowledge
the fact that as we make the plea for
justice
in the court of public opinion
that we pray attorney general
keith ellison will allow us to get more
justice in the court of law
[Applause]
yes
[Music]
maybe that's appropriate
attorney general keith allison
work in tandem with our
civil rights leader pain the activists
and uh
[Music]
has played based on the constitution
of the seventh amendment the civil
rights lawyers played a role in my
god based on the tenth amendment
attorney general keith ellison and his
team of prosecutors
playing
[Applause]
is
[Music]
minneapolis thank you
for not letting the legacy of george
floyd
in for that video we saw 35 star now
on may 25th 2020
[Music]
minorities especially black people have
a right
to get poor gestures not just
and the last thing i will say about this
floyd family
aside from criminal and national
national network
they have become the comforters
and counselors along with our legal team
for the family of dante right
[Music]
just this time last year
america just this time last year
wherever you remember
this time last year
they were being introduced to the world
because
they became part of a fraternity that no
family wants to be a part of
congresswoman obama they evolved
right before our eyes and now
they have not considered property
[Applause]
and
[Music]
[Applause]
accountability
thank you lord thank you very much
family
young man who played the
trumpet presentation for you
all is
the grammy award-winning jazz artist
keon
era
[Applause]
you know the one thing
that the legacy of
dante wright will stand for is this
proposition
that on that video
we did not see the police officer
de-escalate
and the escalation is a behavior
that is intended to prevent the
escalation of conflicts
so katie and aubry
well we saw the video of officer 26 year
veteran was not an exercise in
de-escalation
i would submit to you by co-counseling
that it was
an exercise and escalation but if you
want to see uh exercise and
de-escalation
i have the honor of representing this
man
who most of you came to know
because his 14 year old son was falsely
accused by a blank woman
of stealing an iphone in the harlow
hotel
after the christmas holiday and this
black man
this black man shows the world
how you describe the situation
[Applause]
that is
[Music]
should have exhibited she should have
been
like keon harold so i say
to you as we acknowledge
the families of emmett till
who are present here with us
and the family of oscar
[Applause]
such grant you remember this case
the police officers said they were
reaching for a taste
12 years ago i think about
george ford tragedy and
i read forever now they said what is the
difference
30 years later between
rodney king that we saw
video get brutalized and dehumanized
and tortured by the police and george
floyd
who we saw on video get brutalized
and dehumanized and tortured by the
police
and the answer was very quite simple
it was the quality of technology
has gotten better
but the excessive use of force
remained the same
when you think about de-escalation
is based on behavior
it's based on your behavior
your behavior of a situation many times
is based on your perspective
how you see a thing
i'm reminded
senator kobichardo
ava dubinese how they see us
the legacy in the court of just prudence
will be
how did officer potter
see dante write but more importantly
how does america see our children
because if she saw
your child katie like she saw her child
then i do not think she would
even reach for a taser much less
a gun because
when they see their children they see
their future
they see the best and the brightest
that they have to give the world for the
future
they see the most talented and
resourceful
most indomitable human beings when they
see their children
i submit to you america
so do we when we see our children
i have been notified that philando
castile's mother
is present here let's please acknowledge
[Applause]
[Music]
her
when we talk about how they see us
so
brianna taylor's boyfriend kenny walker
is present here with
us let's recognize kenny walker
all of those who are attached to
people who we loved
that the people were supposed to protect
and serve them
could not see their humanity our
children
so i say in conclusion in this plea for
justice
i remind you again
as i did yesterday but what dr king
told us because at some point
dante junior is going to get old enough
to watch that video
of how his father was slayed so
unnecessarily
a misdemeanor a misdemeanor
reverend l it's too often that
traffic stops end up
as deadly sentences a death sentence
we're going to have to make sure that
dante
junior know
that we stood up for dante
his father and it
is so clear to me that we can't worry
about what people
say about us as we stand up for our
children
dr king said that the coward will ask
the question
is it safe then he said expediency
will ask the question is it politically
correct
then he said vanity would come along
bishop howell and that's the question
is it popular and then
he said conscience
will come along and ask the question
is it right and dr king concluded
there comes a time when one must take a
position
that is neither popular not politically
correct
or not even safe but there comes a time
when one must take a position
because your conscience tells you it is
the right thing to do
it is the right thing to do to stand up
for our children it is the right thing
to do
to speak up for our children it is the
right thing to do
to fight for our children because if we
don't fight for our children
we can't expect nobody else to fight
foul
children like us and we have to fight
for our children
and to hell freezes over and then we
have to be prepared
to fight on the ice because our children
need to know
that's how much we believe in them
that's how much we believe in their
future
because they too have a right to life
in liberty in the american dream and
that is the plea
for justice thank you god bless you
katie and aubry as i prepare
to have reflections
and bring you all up
to reflect on the blessing that god
gave you to bring into this world
i want to take just a moment to
acknowledge
the family of jamar clark who came here
to be with you all
well the wright family is a
beautiful modern
american family
beautiful in every way diverse
lovable
just a representative of america revenal
when you look at them so if you all
will give the charity
of your undivided attention
to the parents of dante wright
as they come to give reflections
his mother katie wright and his
father aubry wright show your love
for this loving family
[Music]
oh
oh i sat up until 3 30 in the morning
so nervous and scared about what i was
gonna stand up here
i never imagined that i'd be standing
here the rules should completely be
reversed my son she buried me
my son had a smile that was worth a
million dollars
when he walked in the room he lit up the
room he was a
brother a joker
he was loved by so many your time katie
i mean um i don't really speak much
but words can't even explain how i feel
right now
you know that was my song
[Applause]
i remember when dante first became a
father
his son was born at 28 weeks
along so he was premature and the joy
that
that junior brought to dante's life was
truly amazing he was so happy and so
proud
and he always said he couldn't wait to
make his son proud
he was just junior was the joy of his
life
and he lived for him every single day
and now he's
god bless you
thank you so much
yeah as
reverend has often said there's no
instructions of
how to join this fraternity
it is thrust upon you
at this time we will have as a
brother his siblings
of dante wright dallas
the meek marcus monica diamond
and destiny if you all will come forward
and give reflections
as a brother
this beautiful american family
my name is monica wright i didn't really
get enough time with him
i wish i got enough
i didn't get to tell him i loved him
before he left
he is deservedly he was so loved by
everybody
do y'all see we all look around and see
how big our family was
my name is dallas i'm one of dante's
three older brothers
and we were pretty much closest out of
the two i spent
a lot of time with this man and
every holiday is not going to be the
same anymore without him being here he
was
literally the life of the park when he
came in you know the smile his
laugh his laugh was really contagious
anybody knows
if you heard his laugh
but i am going to miss this man so much
because he
was literally my best friend through
thick and thin
through all the late night conversations
he had about him trying to
better himself as a man and the man he
wanted to be for junior we
talked for hours on it he was doing that
and
i was just i was so proud of the man
that he was becoming
and he was gonna make an amazing father
to junior
once junior got older throughout the
years and i love my little brother to
death
you all give a big round of applause for
this beautiful american family
turning roman nucha as his aunt nice she
said everybody talked about that big
smile
he had that big smile
and how he lighted up the room
next you will hear from
his uncle bobby wright
the uncle of dante wright
is he coming a long night sure somebody
coming with okay
okay y'all give it up for uncle bobby
oscar grant had an uncle bobby as well
some about those uncle bodies
uh it's funny that uh you say bobby
wright
uh it's bobby mcgee but i was raised
by the wright family my father's bobby
right
and it's a lot of bibles so uh but i
just want to say
you know dante was amazing
he from the first day i met him he was a
little bitty boy
my sister gave him this nickname lemon
head
and uh he would not stop laughing he
wouldn't stop
giggling that smile that laugh was there
from day one
and he drooled when he was a baby none
stopped so he just couldn't stop
laughing all the time
so he just brightened the room and i
tell you you know
it's not gonna be the same without him
i'm just so thankful that i had the
opportunity
to spend my last birthday with him and i
wish i could tell you that i was
spending his birthday with him
but we won't have that opportunity
you know this is just a travesty we just
got to do better as people
we can't keep
i actually wrote something for him but
um
you know with all this going on i just
don't know if i can do that
but i love you
i love you dante
[Applause]
next we will have a musical selection
and then i will introduce
the eulogist who really needs no
introduction but i
it would be disrespectful not to give
him his propers
now we'll have the musical selection
[Music]
i wish
me
my eyes
[Music]
to
[Music]
from
[Music]
[Music]
you are the
source of my strength
[Applause]
[Music]
true
[Music]
[Music]
will
[Music]
my hair
[Music]
[Applause]
give me
[Music]
you
[Music]
is
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
right
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Applause]
wow
[Applause]
oh
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
my lord y'all
thank bishop howe and his
incredible choir from shallow
temple international ministry
[Music]
bishop howe thank you for having your
great choir here
so all of america could take in
the fullness of the black church
experience
so when those who don't attend the black
church when they go to their church on
sunday
they can reflect back to the black
church experience
thank you bishop however
amen
now has come the time
when we pay the highest respects to
dante wright with the eulogy
and there is nobody more
fitting than
our civil rights leader in america today
every time i call him he always answers
the bail
he answered the bail for martin lee
anderson in 2006 he answered the bill
for trayvon
martin in 2012 oscar grant in 2009
he answered the bail for every
name we have come to learn
in the last three decades
of black people who have been
disenfranchised victimized and
marginalized
he answers the call in the middle of the
night
the wee hours of the morning
even when he's doing his television show
politics nation
he will text you back because that's how
much he cares
about black america
and those who have been forgotten about
left behind swept under the rug
he always is there
standing in the gap giving a voice to
the voiceless
my mentor my
friend he's a co-counselor when we need
him
kayden aubry and he is
the man who god has anointed
for a time such as this the
reverend al sharpton
give an honor to god
to our pastor give a big hand to bishop
howe
[Applause]
two of my brother aubry and sister katie
and to the whole family and to those
that have sat in that seat
families that are here that have sat in
that seat
know better than any of us how they feel
i don't care how much settlement they
may be given
you can never fill the hole in their
heart
that was caused for no reason
that is why they're here give those
mothers
fathers and uncles of victims that come
to their big hand
[Applause]
in the tradition of the black church we
take a
text and a subject and i didn't want to
disrespect
bishop so i went to the book of isaiah
today they tell me this is grandma's
birthday
i'm a little older than her so i gotta
read my reading glasses
book of isaiah 59th chapter
eighth and the ninth verse
says they the way of peace
they know not and there is no
judgment in their goings
therefore is judgment far from us
neither does justice overtake us
i want to use for a subject no justice
no peace
1986 in a section of brooklyn called
howard beach
young man named michael griffith was
killed
because they said that they didn't allow
blacks
in the neighborhood some of us went out
and marched
and during the march one brother yelled
i believe his name was armor wallet no
justice
no peace and it became the chant
of our movement some of us have made it
popular but it started there
but it really started in the bible
because isaiah said
that those that practice injustice
cannot practice peace
the absence of justice
is the absence of peace and when we say
that we're not talking about violence
because there is a confusion in this
country
between peace and quiet
some of us are told
to shut up and just be quiet
and you call that peace but peace is the
presence of justice you can't tell us to
shut up and suffer
we must speak up when there is an
injustice i i
remember as i was riding here and i saw
someone and as i got out the car to meet
the family to ride
to the church heard a man say i've not
seen a funeral procession like this
since prince in minneapolis
i said well we came to bury the prince
of brooklyn
we come from all over the country
because you hurt one of our princes
that's why we're in this temple with
purple all over
cause it represents royalty you thought
he was just some
kid with air freshener he was a prince
and all of minneapolis has stopped today
to honor the prince of brooklyn center
if you knew who we were
if you understood what dividends that
god made
if you understood that his mother
and father broke the racial barrier
lines
and raised him in an interracial home
that used to be against the law but they
defied the color barriers
a black man and a white woman enraged
children
to not hate nobody and he was a prince
of that raising if you knew who he was
you have been caught
with mistaken identity you keep thinking
that we are somebody we're not
they tell our young folks
to don't go to the streets and march
when marching and it's protesting
is a way of correcting the injustice
isaiah talked about you can't go to
church
on sunday and read this book
that we call the bible and not fight
against oppression
god is not on the side of the oppressor
god is on the side of the oppressed
for every pharaoh there was a moses
for every nebuchadnezzar there was a
daniel
for every belches out there with three
hebrew boys for every inherit there was
a
jesus we come in the tradition
of what god's plan was and when you
oppress us we must stand up
that's why we're here
11 months ago we stood
for george floyd and as the trial
wound down and the jury was about to get
diverted
and the reason we got the jury we got
and the verdict we got is god
used a young brother
born and raised in as a muslim
but believing in the same god don't
matter how you approach
god and elected him
even after you tried to scandalize him
the attorney general of the state of
[Applause]
minnesota
god doesn't use folk without
letting you test them
everybody that god calls
he lets you baptize them in fire
they indicted martin luther king it only
got him ready for what he did
every time you were under attack you
just getting ready
because god wouldn't test you if he
wasn't gonna graduate you
and he was being tested and elected
so that he was prepared to take the
attacks
when he stood up for george floyd and
was able for the first time in the
history
of the state of minnesota to convict a
white
policeman for killing a black man
two murder convictions and one
slot one manslaughter conviction
god has turned the page in the state of
minnesota
and we're never going back no more
yes some of us have different tactics
but all of us have the same goal
talk about some of y'all the civil
rights some of y'all the street
activists
we all street activists and we all civil
rights
all of some of us young some of us old
but we all the same they don't
discriminate us because they age
and that's why when i talked to brother
aubrey
and told him that we'd be there for him
whatever he needs
because we see this young man
as royalty when ben crump called me the
other night
and told me that they were winding the
trial down you better come in
i had certain obligations and i had to
fulfill them in new york couldn't get
here the way i wanted i called one of my
wealthy black friends he said i'll send
you my plane
some of them got on twitter talking
about why i'm on the previous plane
because i'm that kind of guy
[Applause]
when george floyd was killed
tyler paris sent his private plane to
bring the floyd family to minneapolis
robert smith sent a private plane to
bring eric garner's mother and me into
phillip
into minneapolis we ain't in the back of
the bus
no more
i had to take an apollo rocket if it was
available
every crisis must
be answered though with real change
yesterday the attorney general garland
announced a study of the
practices the practices
in minnesota
and that is going to lead to where it
goes but now
we are fighting for federal law
why federal law because if we keep
having to fight
state by state we'll never solve this
the generation before me they
boycotted in montgomery against the
segregation laws in alabama
and they boycotted the bus company
1955 they started december 1st
and for a solid year they wouldn't ride
the bus
they said it was better to walk in
dignity
to ride in shame and they broke the
backs
of alabama segregation but dr
king and dr abernathy and rosa parks
said we can't stop there
we got to have federal law and they went
their way
then some young students the young folk
of that day they became freedom riders
and
others did other things and it took nine
years
and they got the civil rights act
federally
that made it against federal law
congresswoman omar
to discriminate well we've gone from
all of these abuses from oscar grant
and amadou diallo and others all the way
to philando castille right here
in minneapolis area we
struggled through all of that but we are
going to now
in his name in the name of dante we're
going to pass the george
floyd justice in policing act
as federal law we are
going to make it against the law all
over this country
to keep bringing us to funerals for our
young princes
this is not a republican or democratic
thing
isaiah said it's about justice
if you believe in justice
it's time for the federal government
to reflect the will of the people you
couldn't have a better picture
than to have two people that cross the
color line
and raise children to be somebody
to stand up and embrace them you
couldn't have had a bad example in the
floyd family
that wiped tears from their eyes and
stood up with dignity
even as they watch them smear their
brother
their uncle their father
we've always had to take the smearing
keith ellison but behind every dark
night
the sun will shine
[Applause]
i was talking to one of the relatives
and
i said well why are they what are they
trying to justify they said
one said well they said they saw some
air fresheners in the back of his car
well
air fresheners is to keep the bad odors
out
where we come today as the air
fresheners
for minnesota we're trying to get the
stench
of police brutality out of the
atmosphere
we're trying to get the stench of racism
out of the atmosphere
we're trying to get the stench of racial
profiling
out of the atmosphere we come to
minnesota
as air freshness because your air
is too odorous for us to breathe we
can't breathe in your stinking air no
more
i know we got to get to the cemetery but
let me tell you this
the time has come for america to stand
up and bring a new day to where we don't
have to explain
our children what to do when the police
stop you
it's time to bring a new day where we
don't have to videotape
when we see a badge but where we know
that they're there to serve and protect
not treat us like we've been convicted
the time has come for police to
understand they're not above the law
they're to enforce the law and if you
can't live
up to the badge don't take the oath and
put it on
when we put that badge on you we expect
you to act like
somebody that is civilized and
respectful some say rather now
police are human well we knew that
otherwise we wouldn't have sent you
through training
but we assumed when you come through
that you were trained
train people don't confuse guns from
tasers
train people don't shoot
men like philando with a child in the
backseat
train people don't put knees on people's
necks for nine minutes and 29 seconds
train people don't shoot 41 times
and i'ma do diallo train people
don't shoot at a young 12 year old boy
named tamir rice
you broke your training now we gonna
send you to the corner
and you get your punishment at the
corner
of the newest jail that we can find
so as we celebrate this young man's life
20 years old not even
reaching his mid-20s
his mother and father heart broken
his siblings heartbroken but they
will be comforted knowing that because
of this sacrifice that is going to
change the laws of the land
children unborn he's going to know his
name
governor's here congress people here
senators here
for you dante cause you were the prince
that made us all come together
they stopped traffic today all the way
through minneapolis
folk couldn't drive nowhere because they
had to say hell
to the prince they shouldn't have done
what they've done
we're going to stop minneapolis today
because a prince
is on his way to his rest and as you
rest
there's a resting place there's a
martyr's bench
take your seat dante tell george floyd
who you are
take your seat dante shake hands with
phillip
for philando castillo take your seat
take your seat next to oscar grant
because there's a special place in
heaven
for those that shed innocent blood
because
god will use you to straighten out the
world
the world will never be the same because
we're going to stand up
for situations like this
we do not in any way
condone or incite violence
people keep telling me reverend why
don't y'all tell people not to be
violent we always have but when are you
going to tell policemen to stop being
violent
problem is not us talking to our youth
the problem is you talking to your bad
cops
now all cops are not bad i saw
10 get on the stand the other day
and testify against another policeman
that's why no change is here when you
see the blue wall of silence
tumble in a courtroom in minneapolis
when policemen understand that they are
committed to the oath
rather than to their colleague that's
when we know a breakthrough is coming
that's when we know we can pass the
george floyd bill
because folk are not going to lie on you
no more
and next time you get ready to pull your
gun
next time you get ready to bend your
knee put
in your mind the picture of the man
taking the handcuffs and making chauvin
put his hands behind his back
and walk into a penitentiary and learn
that you will pay
for the crimes you commit
as i talked closer to the family
they said that well the real reason they
stopped
was because his tags had expired
well i come to minnesota
to tell you your tags have expired
your tags of racism has expired
your tags of police brutality has
expired
your tags of white supremacy has expired
your tags are looking at us different
than everybody else
has expired your tags have expired
it's time to renew and get some new tags
a tags of righteousness attacks of
fairness
attacks of treating everybody the same
way
attacks of no justice no peace
lastly
when i come
to minneapolis three days after
george floyd
was killed lynched by me
i went to one of the rod marches
and i saw almost as many whites as
blacks
now your children are doing what you
wouldn't do
standing up for justice we called
martin luther king the 39
national action network called the march
in washington
august 28th anniversary of his father's
march
people told me don't call it it's a
pandemic
it's going to be a super spreader but
204
000 people came we tested them all we
did all we were supposed to do to see
what
way we could avoid any breaking
out of covet coming in
and we marched around the george floyd
justice in policing act we marched
around the john lewis voting act because
they're trying to turn back
voting rights those tags done expired
too that ain't gonna happen no more
and we marched all over march for
brianna taylor whose boyfriend is here
with us today
some went and stayed down there
and stood up for brianna getting ready
to go march for pamela turner
may 13th in texas i hope you all
live in texas we on the way
because your tags have expired
we gonna stop by north carolina where a
young man was shot yesterday
we gonna look in columbus ohio your tags
have expired
we're going wherever you show up because
your tags
have expired in the name of the prophet
isaiah
we are not going to be quiet as long as
there is no justice
i want you to know that this bible
that you claim you believe in
you need to stop quoting it and start
reading it
it's a bible of justice
and if you don't understand it talk to
some of us
that read it straight i know y'all had a
president that holds it upside down but
turn it right side up
cause if you turn it right side up
and you get to the end of the book
at the end of revelation god made a
promise
albright god made a promise katie
he said the first shall be last
and the last shall be first
and the lion and the lamb gonna lay down
together
and god will take care of his children
god will make a way out of no nowhere
god will heal the land god
will take care dante now stand up
and be what we were born to be we are
not
anyone's slaves we're the children of
god we're the children of god
we're the children of god
before we leave
we became cousins today
we want the family first but we want
some of those that have come
to recognize the princeless
state that we're here
and to give proclamations they ought to
be here
whether you agree with them or not they
should be here to respect
who he was and what he stood for
i read he was the center when he played
basketball in school
now he's the center of a movement of god
i want his brothers and sisters
to keep your mother and father covered
because it won't be long
for these crowds to be gone flanders
mother could tell you that
everybody's here when the cameras are
here
but when the cameras go a lot of your
new cousins ain't gonna be there
[Music]
and y'all gonna have to keep the family
together
this policewoman is charged
you're gonna have to go through a long
trial
and they're gonna try things to not have
a trial
but stay by your mother and father some
of us will be here
and others will come when the cameras
come back
i don't worry about the cameras i got my
own tv show i ain't trying to get on tv
but stay strong and stay together
i saw his auntie on tv she preached
better than any preacher up here
stand up auntie
i want us to hear some proclamations and
words
let me start with another one that had
been
smeared they got tested and they passed
the test
let us hear from our congresswoman ilyan
omar
[Applause]
salaam alaikum everyone
thank you reverend ultron for being
here and for that beautiful
eulogy most
of us in this room including myself look
at you
as a guardian and are blessed
to be in your presence and may
dante wright serve as a guardian for all
of us
but as a member of the congressional
black caucus
as one of the youngest and newest
members of the congressional black
caucus
i also have guardians
congresswoman sheila jackson lee and our
chairwoman
joyce beatty serve as guardians for me
and many of my colleagues
joyce beatty was going to be here and
speak on our behalf
as the chairwoman of our caucus
but just like we've been visited by
tragedy here in minnesota
often she in columbus ohio
was visited by a tragedy of a young
woman whose life was taken
by columbus police
and so i um
wanted to read a little bit
of the resolution of congressional
condolences
that our guardian congresswoman sheila
jackson lee filed
on behalf of our son dante right
here in minnesota
whereas dante demetrius wright
attended thomas edison high school in
minneapolis
which i'm an alum of
and blaine high school in blaine
minnesota
after high school he studied at the
university of minnesota
twin cities in minneapolis dante
demetrius wright
had a son born in july 2019
dante demetrius wright named his son
dante demetrius wright jr
and we are today confront
comforted by the words of our lord
in the revelation 21
4 which says
and god shall wipe away all tears from
their eyes
and there shall be no more death
neither sorrow nor crying
neither shall there be any more pain
for the former things that passed away
no words can really help
ease the pain is the
no words can really help to ease the
loss
you bear just know that your family and
friends are very close
in every thought and prayer
may the outpouring of sympathy
the kinds of acts of friends and
strangers
the comfort in knowing that your loss is
felt
by many help you through this
dante demetrius wright brought great joy
to his family and his life was a
blessing
to all who had the privilege to know him
dante demetrius wright is survived and
cherished
by his father aubry wright
and his mother katie wright
and his son dante wright jr
and a host of family and friends
and his legacy will live
we also wanted to present this to his
mom and dad
if you all can come we flew a flag
over the united states capital on behalf
of your son
and i wanted to present the flag to you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
let them stay here a minute we got
something else to present them
all of this they deserve when
george floyd was killed
and we wanted the best prosecution
my mentor reverend jesse jackson and i
called the governor
the governor talked to the d.a who
graciously stepped back
and allowed the attorney general to be
the prosecutor
that did such a great job and the
governor is here with us today for the
proclamation from the state
as governor of minnesota on behalf of
the entire state and our population
we extend our deepest condolences to the
wright family
and issue the following proclamation
to honor the life and memory of dante
wright
whereas dante wright was beloved by his
family's
neighbors community and had his entire
young life ahead of him
we mourn that loss we know that this
tragedy
is connected to the deep and systemic
racism in our society
that black people in minnesota and
across this country face every single
day
while nothing will bring dante right
back to his loved ones
we must continue to enact real
meaningful change at the local
state and national levels to fight
systemic racism
so that every single person in minnesota
black
indigenous brown and white can be safe
and thrive
we must be steadfast in our
accountability to change from the top
to the bottom and not rest until we
create a different future for dante
wright's son
and every other child like him now
now therefore i tim wells governor of
minnesota
had ordered a moment of silence for two
minutes across the entire state of
minnesota at 12 p.m on thursday april
22nd
to honor the life and memory of dante
wright in his family and friends
as they lay him to rest and remember
that every person whose life has been
cut short
due to systemic and racism and
discrimination will not be forgotten
in order to pass the george floyd bill
that has already passed the house
we need to pass it in the senate
we have the advocate from the senate
your senate and minnesota senator amy
globacher
thank you so much uh reverend now
and thank you bishop powell for allowing
me to join you in this sacred space
uh thank you to mr and mrs wright
and asking me to close out
is saying a few words in your son's
memory
i don't have a proclamation for you to
give
in a piece of paper i've got a
proclamation in the senate
and that is that we must pass the george
floyd
justice and policing act
[Applause]
you know there's a photo
of your son of dante that many americans
have seen by now
he's standing outdoors on a sparkling
day
holding his son dante jr and he's got
this big smile on his
smile that you said katie would light up
the room
we see the lively outgoing young man who
always made people laugh
who was lovingly voted class clown his
freshman year by his high school class
we see the basketball fan whose
left-handed shot would make any coach
proud
most of all we see dante's radiant love
for his family as he holds
his baby boy in the photo dante jr wears
a colorful
bib with polka dots and a bow tie
and the words first birthday printed in
cheerful letters
across the front and that's when we see
the enormous
hole dante leaves in the world that's
when we remember
that he won't be there for his son's
second birthday
or high school graduation or to see
those
to see those grandkids racism
racism in this country is not isolated
it is systemic and so
when we ask ourselves why donte junior
has to grow up without a dad
when we think about what could possibly
fill this whole dante left in the world
we come up empty instead we find
a much bigger hole where justice should
be
that word is so heavy on our minds this
week
justice two days ago in a courtroom not
ten miles from where dante was shot a
jury found derek chovin guilty
guilty of the murder of george floyd and
the nation owes a debt a gratitude to
the floyd family thank you for being
here
to my friend attorney general keith
ellison
who's by the way reverend now if i could
introduce his family keith's family
who has had his back right there if they
could stand up
he's family his wife monica they had his
back through everything
and to ben crump reverend
reverend jesse jackson all those in my
state who have been warriors for justice
and yet while this was a historic moment
for our country
we cannot confuse accountability for
justice
because true justice is not done as long
as having expired tags means losing your
life
during a traffic stop true justice is
not done as long as a chokehold a knee
on the neck
or a no knock warrant is considered
legitimate policing
true justice is not done as long as
black americans are killed by law
enforcement
at more than twice the rate of white
americans
and to use your words katie true
justice is not done as long as your son
isn't coming home for dinner
our hearts ate for dante in part because
so many people
in this room and throughout our state
can imagine being 20 years old
driving around their neighborhood on a
sunday afternoon yes even
with expired registration tags yes even
with
an air freshener hanging from the rear
view mirror many young people can
imagine calling
their mom their mom when they need
insurance information
or when they're scared but only some
can imagine being shot by a police
officer during a traffic stop
only some could imagine that this phone
call would be their last
only some live that with that fear
every single day and that
mr crump as you know is the definition
of injustice during that groundbreaking
trial
george floyd's family members a store
clerk
a firefighter passerby as well as as you
noted reverend al
a number of police officers testified
about george floyd and what happened
that day
they told the truth they said it was
wrong
and we heard darnell fraser a teenager
who testified having witnessed george
floyd murder say
it's been nights i stay up apologizing
and apologizing
for george floyd for not doing more
could she have done more
no it was not on her to change what
happened that faithful day
and it's not on people who nearly a year
later happened to be at the intersection
of 63rd and orchard in brooklyn center
to change what happened to dante it is
on
us as leaders in our communities in our
neighborhoods as lawmakers
we can do more we must do more because
for too long change has come
inch by inch when we should be miles
ahead
it is time for washington d.c to move
forward on police reform and pass
the george floyd justice in policing act
we must make policing more accountable
we have to change police training and
standards
including banning chokeholds which my
colleague senator smith
is leading the bill to ban chokeholds
along with myself she is up here with me
on this stage
we have to change the status quo so that
driving while black
doesn't result in getting shot this
this is the urgent task before us not
for tomorrow when i go back to
washington not for tomorrow
not for next year but for now true
justice so as we remember dante's life
and grieve his death we must repair
what's broken in this country and make
sure
class counts and basketball fans
doting fathers and caring sons remain
with
us in body as dante
now does in spirit mrs
wright and we won't rest until
justice true justice is done
that's my proclamation
we are getting ready to go
let me again thank our warrior
the attorney general of black america
ben
crump give him a lot of love
a day before the final funeral
of george floyd in houston
then candidate joe biden came to houston
and met
with the floyd family and ben crump and
i
and showed us sensitivity he's called
them since then
he's met with the civil rights
organization heads
convened by mark morial the president of
the national urban league who's here
and he said he would meet periodically
and we're calling on the president to
meet
there needs to be a white house meeting
on how we deal with these police
incidents one right after another
that he and the vice president are
committed to
there needs to be a meeting with the
attorney general we call for it
right here in this funeral this morning
we have many
mayors here and we're glad that they're
all
present and we are happy that you're
here
we want the family to go out first the
ministers will lead them out
then i want activist groups not just
those of us
that are known but those that's been
marching in the streets
that made this happen many of you
need to walk behind the family because
you made this happen and then
our head of youth and college nash
action network minister tully
uh macmillan my youngest daughter's with
me ashley sharpton reverend
bartlett where's until freedom they've
been marching all over for brianna
where they at tell them that we want
them to march with us
we want to go together naacp
urban league all of us mark walked with
the ministers please
as we lead the family out
and make sure that you put your red
light on
because some tags have expired and we
got to pull them over
for the new law the george floyd law
the lord bless you and keep you
the lord make his faces shine upon you
and be gracious unto you
the lord lift up his countenance and
give you peace
in jesus name amen
[Music]
so
[Music]
i am not all by myself
i don't need
any help i can't hear
[Applause]
where i am
[Applause]
[Music]
i
was there in
the peak
[Music]
to the
[Music]
where i am i
am i am
i was there
in the beginning
and i'll be there
when you get to the end
[Music]
i am i am
for i am i
am i am
i am
[Music]
all of my promises my promises
hi i oh
[Applause]
[Applause]
oh
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
[Applause]
oh
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
i
[Music]
am
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
[Applause]
[Music]
i am
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i am
i am
where i am
foreign
okay
come here
back up
[Music]
oh
oh
right here
thank you
uh
come on
[Music]
oh
is
everybody
thank you
okay
[Music]
wow
100.
[Music]
okay
important
there you go
we love you al sharkin we love you
brother
power to the people
hey hold on baby
[Music]
uh
okay
[Music]
come over here
i want everybody
until i pass across again
[Music]
lined up now
okay
foreign
y'all
that's enough space right there
once every day
thank you
i just got up here
oh
[Music]
oh
[Music]
videos
oh
uh
oh
fight
oh great
step up
oh
oh
okay
okay
move them
think about that
great
yeah but i kind of see it as apples and
oranges i mean it's great it's totally
the thing i like about that
[Music]
is
so
what
marathon still we walking
[Music]
[Music]
hey
yes
she was over here
right
[Music]
um
goodbye